nouvel épisode de notre série dans son
corps cette fois notre invité vient pas
tellement nous parler de sa
particularité physique à elle mais
plutôt de celle des personnes dont elle
s'occupe je vous en dis pas plus pour
pas vous spoiler mais disons
qu'aujourd'hui on se retrouve pour une
vidéo un peu particulière qui l'aurait
vais dire ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
marie poiré et orthophoniste mais elle a
une spécialité que vous connaissez
peut-être pas elle va vous expliquer ça
bonjour marie donc toi tu es
orthophoniste de métier mais tu
t'occupes pas tellement de la voix des
gens tu fais pas tellement de la
rééducation pour les gens qui dégaine ou
kids à tous toi c'est quoi ta spécialité
alors ma spécialité à moi c'est de
travailler en fait dans l'alimentation
et les troubles de l'alimentation
générale on va rentrer dans les détails
un petit peu après mais globalement pour
que les gens comprennent bien ça
consiste en quoi exactement les troupes
de l'oralité alimentaire en fait la
définition
générale c'est toutes les difficultés
qui touchent à l'alimentation par voie
orale donc c'est hyper large et on verra
qu effectivement au niveau des symptômes
et va saper s'exprimer de manière hyper
différentes on se rend bien compte en
entendant ça que ça peut englober plein
de choses c'est pas forcément quelque
chose qui est connu du grand public
pourtant tu vas peut-être arrêter si je
me trompe mais j'ai lu que ça toucherait
un enfant sur quatre faut toujours faire
attention avec les chiffres cette
statistique là on utilise un petit peu
pour marquer l'esprit pour que les gens
se rendent compte que c'est quand même
répondu pour te donner le détail en fait
on peut dire que un enfant sur quatre
est touché ou a été touchée par les
troupes de l'oralité alimentaire
évidemment chez certains ça va être
super discret et les particularités
sensorielle vont être tellement légère
qu on s'en rendra jamais compte en fait
et puis chez d'autres ça peut devenir
très rapidement d'enfer est menée dans
le pire des cas à une hospitalisation à
de la dénutrition est donc
à la pause d'une alimentation en terre
on parle de son descendant de mai qui
vont dans l'estomac pour envoyer des
nutriments aux enfants qui mangent pas
principalement tornado en fait à la
sonde naso-gastrique ont activement et
d'ailleurs le ton de gastro du coup un
peu plus concrètement comment ça peut se
manifester chez des enfants puisque non
récurrents c'est quand même beaucoup
beaucoup de cette population là qu'on
parle mais comment ça se peut se
manifester les troupes de l'oralité
alimentaire les troupes de la qualité
alimentaire tu vas globalement avoir des
enfants au fait qu'ils mangent
pas assez et pas assez variés donc tu
vas avoir souvent ce qu'on appelle parmi
les symptômes ne t'a pas obligé de tout
avoir mais parmi les symptômes on va
retrouver la néophobie alimentaire donc
la peur des nouveaux aliments la
sélectivité alimentaire donc là des
enfants ou des adultes qui vont trier
par forme par couleur par textures
parfois par température les gens qui
vont manger pas du tout chaud non pas du
tout froid
tu vas pouvoir retrouver bah forcément
des troubles du comportement au moment
du repas les enfants qui vont se mettre
à hurler à pleurer à se cacher
la lenteur des repas tu vas avoir des
mots pas qu'ils vont être anormalement
long en moyenne pour un enfant et autour
de 20 à 30 minutes là tu as des enfants
qui peuvent être une heure trente de
bonheur et puis ensuite il ya aussi
souvent univers sensibilité associés
donc un peu plus généralisé de type
hyper sensibilité tactile avec des
enfants qui ont du mal à toucher des
textures alors souvent ceux des textures
un peu collante un peu salissante des
enfants qui ont du mal à se salir
et puis tu peux aussi avoir d'autres
symptômes un peu plus discret un peu
moins connu un peu moins représentatifs
comme l'a dit si donc vous fûtes
s'hydrater ça peut aussi faire partir
après t'as plein d'autres petits
symptômes et normalement quand on
commence à avoir tout ça je dis rien
c'est dans ce cas tu as parce que ce que
tu ce que tu décris là c'est ce que dans
le langage courant on appelle des
enfants difficiles en fait du coup est
ce que ça veut dire que un enfant
difficile c'est un enfant qui a des
troubles
l'oralité alimentaire ou ou est-ce que
ça peut être autre chose alors ça peut
être autre chose et c'est là que c'est
un peu difficile parce que forcément on
va pas prendre en charge et vous avez
même faut savoir que la néophobie
alimentaire donc la peur de goûter le
refus les nouveaux éléments c'est une
période pour trouve dans le
développement normal de l'enfant donc
entre 2 et 10 ans et plus spécifiquement
entre 4 et 7 ans l'enfant va pas vouloir
goûter de nouveaux aliments et puis tu
vas quand tu vas lui faire goûter un
truc qui va dire j'aime pas globalement
mais chez les enfants qui vous bien
cette période là va être dépassé par
l'apprentissage par la curiosité puis
par l'envié aussi de faire comme les
grands alors que chez l'enfant qui est
un trouble on n'y sur du caprice ni un
manque d envie on est vraiment sur un
blocage est quelque chose de l'ordre de
la phobie donc quelque chose de beaucoup
plus fort tu donne l exemple de trier
les aliments par couleurs textures etc
on entend souvent dire mon enfant tout
ce qui est vert c'est
c'est et rejette donc ça c'est le genre
de truc qui rentrent dans le cadre de de
se trouver là ouais oui et on retrouve
aussi notamment très souvent en autisme
enfants porteurs d'autisme sont très
représentés en fait on estime qu environ
80% de ces enfants là vont avoir un truc
de l'oralité alimentaire pomper et à eux
sont connus pour ça parce que ils sont
quand même souvent cette spécificité sur
la couleur donc mais on peut aussi le
retrouver chez un enfant tout venant
donc qui a pas de pathologie associée
souvent quand même ils mangent plutôt
jaune plutôt blanc rarement tous vers le
genre de carte des pâtes des frites pas
trop de brocolis et bricoleur oui ça
s'explique 1 explique aussi en fait
c'est des enfants qui vont être rassurés
pas les arguments hyper transformé parce
que forcément en fait entre une pâte qui
sont les pires
les pires accès simple et c'est aussi
pour ça qu'ils passent pour des enfants
capricieux voit ce qu'on dit mais attend
il est capable de ma chair un bonbon et
de croquer une chips mais par contre il
peut pas manger des haricots verts en
fait c'est normal les animaux ultra
transformés sont plus faciles à digérer
à manger ils ont été pensés pour ça donc
c'est des aliments qui vont fondre en
bouche qui vont s'amalgamer facilement
avec la salive et ça va aller simplement
et en plus c'est des aliments qui vont
avoir une certaine stabilité donc toutes
les pâtes du même paquet par des amis
partout dans le monde vont avoir le même
temps mahmoud voilà alors que de
haricots c'est quoi jamais deux pommes
qui ont exactement vraiment le même goût
selon la saison selon la couleur et c
est ce manque de confiance là dans
l'alimentation il est hyper important
chez eux et s il ya une mauvaise
expérience tu peux être sûr
tu parlais des des enfants qui ont des
troubles de la statistique mais de
manière plus globale est ce qu'il y à
quoi les causes des troupes de l'oralité
alimentaire à ce concept on a quelques
quelques causes et quelques facteurs de
risque donc effectivement tu vas avoir
tout tous les handicaps les maladies les
maladies génétiques etc
là ils vont être présentés effectivement
hauteur de 80% et puis ensuite on va
avoir notamment la prématurité alors pas
forcément pour les raisons qu'on croit
déjà effectivement c'est des enfants qui
naissent qui n'ont pas qu'ils sont pas
qu'ils ont pas toujours le développement
nécessaire pour se mettre à manger
correctement qui parfois n'ont même pas
la force de traiter correctement manger
correctement mais en plus en fait ça va
surtout être liés à toutes les
intrusions au niveau de la soeur au
pastel tous les gestes médicaux un petit
peu désagréable qui vont subir donc mal
a encore surtout ceux qui sont sondés
ça peut aussi être et ben des cause
traumatique alors ça a l'air énorme
comme ça en fait une grosse somme est
une cause traumatique c'est quelque
chose qui va venir avoir un impact au
niveau de la sphère orale donc les
opérations les hospitalisations et puis
là encore en fait une grosse infection
orl ça peut suffire un enfant qui rentre
à l'hôpital en fait ce qu'il peut
suffire de 2 3 jours pour qu'ils
désapprouvent à manger et que savait pas
été très agréable c'est un peu fou tu es
et quand tu parlais de d'alimentation
donc entérale donc par sonde ou
j'imagine peut-être parentérale aussi
les enfants qui sont nourris par
perfusion le fait que pendant ce temps
là ils mangent pas du tout par la bouche
est ce que c'est quelque chose est ce
qu'on pense que c'est quelque chose
qu'il joue aussi ouais je parlais de
désapprendre à manger ou pas apprendre à
voler dans le cas des prématurés ouais
ouais ouais ça joue et il est alors soit
ils n'apprennent pas comme tu dis soit
aidé apprennent et en fait ça va hyper
vite donc dans ces cas là il faut pas
hésiter à se préparer et malheureusement
c'est pas hyper connue en fait les gens
pas forcément le réflexe mais faire
sentir des odeurs à son bébé lui amener
des odeurs de la maison lui fait
ressentir des choses évidemment quand
c'est possible ce que pointe soit en
couveuse il faut l'accord de l'équipe
médicale mais lui faire découvrir des
shows touché des textures etc pour
essayer un petit peu de combler le
retard si vraiment l'enfant est dans un
état trop critique et que c'est pas
possible eh ben c'est aussi des choses
qu'on peut mettre en place quand on
rentre à la maison mais clairement un
enfant qui est sondé ça peut durer
parfois des années ou continue de
l'accompagner et de lui proposer des
choses par la bouche alors on prend
d'autant qu'il ya plus l'urgence vitale
mais par contre on continue de
progresser du coup toi quand tu prends
en charge des enfants quand ce type de
trouble qu'est ce que tu fais ce que tu
veux avec eux
surtout que alors moi je prends j'ai
vraiment des patients de la naissance à
l'âge adulte du centre de ma passion qui
la plus âgée à 46 ans j'ai pas mal
d'ados forcément on fait pas les mêmes
faux mais globalement tu vas avoir trois
axes tu vas avoir un max sensoriel où
effectivement va bien désensibiliser un
petit peu parce que c'est des enfants
très très sensible parfois certains
bébés tu leur touche les lèvres ils
peuvent au mieux parce qu'ils ont ce
réflexe nauséeux qui est très exacerbée
donc sensorielle on va toucher d'abord
au niveau des mains puis monter au
niveau du visage puis de la bouche etc
ça peut passer par des massages des
vibrations et tout et puis ensuite on a
un axe moteur parce qu'il ya quelque
chose qu'on ne dit pas forcément souvent
on entend beaucoup parler du sensoriel
mais on a besoin de vérifier que ces
enfants là peuvent manger en termes
vraiment moteurs ont récité et ce qu'ils
ont la capacité motrice à effectuer les
mouvements nécessaires pour manger un
aliment parce qu'en fait c'est beaucoup
plus complexe que ce qu'on croit il faut
de la force de l'endurance de la
précision donc ça c'est très important
de le vérifier et si une orthophoniste
détecte un problème à ce niveau là elle
va pouvoir proposer une prise en charge
là aussi à base d'exercices simples
comme de la musculation la musculation
delà de la sphère orange exactement au
de la langue stabilité de mâchoire et
s'est donc ça peut être un peu
fastidieux mais ça marche très très bien
et puis le dernier axe est vraiment
l'acte alimentaire parce que si tu
restes sur la sensorialité et puis faire
des petits exercices en fait c'est pas
pour ça que demain en fin de la semaine
avec 70 nouveaux aliments est donc là on
va avoir plusieurs techniques pour
étendre le spectre de ce que l'enfant
peut manger partir d'aliments tu connais
pour aller vers des éléments nouveaux
donc ça veut dire en gros pour tous de
la partie alimentaire toi quand tu
reçois des
jeunes moins jeunes patients ça veut
dire que dans son cabinet à tulle et tu
les fais manger tue les tuent les tuent
les confronte à différents types de
dalles immense et c'est que c'est quoi
exactement là le processus de
réconciliation avec avec la nourriture
webb est alors déjà énormément sous
forme de jeu on passe tout sous forme de
jeux faut que ce soit fun faut que ce
soit ludique ce que deux jeux seulement
monsieur aussi qu'ils auront pas envie
de venir et ce qui est très important
c'est 'qui on les confronte à nouveaux
aliments mais le but et c'est là tout le
travail du professionnel c'est de
trouver ce qu'on appelle sa zone
proximale de développement ça veut dire
que on est proche de ce qui s'est déjà
fait mais à trop loin non plus c'est à
dire que c'est quelque chose de nouveau
mais qu'on va le mettre en réussite
c'est à dire que si j'ai un enfant qui
ne mangent que des pâtes si demain je
lui amène je reçois rien une clémentine
une tomate ça va être hyper compliqué et
je veux le mettre en échec hyper dommage
donc on va choisir ensemble on va créer
ce qu'on appelle des chaînages avec les
parents en fonction de leurs envies
leurs besoins ce qui est à la maison
aussi et on va amener comme ça les
aliments petit à petit et le but dans
l'idéal c'est qu'ils réussissent tout
temps donc on fait beaucoup de jeu on en
fous partout régulièrement mon bureau
sans les épices fin de semaine ça à vrai
plaisir meiway en général c'est beaucoup
de jeux de pas tout
et je suis beaucoup les intérêts de
l'enfant parce que je trouve que déjà
c'est plus sympa comme ça et puis ils
sont tellement tous différents que c'est
en les suivant eux qu'on va y arriver
donc si s'engouffre dans une brèche et
je les suis ça part dans tous les sens
en gros si je résume tu me dis si je me
trompe si je résume en disant que tu
pars de ce qu'il est ce que ce que
l'enfant est habitué à manger genre des
pâtes et que tu veux à la mener à des
brocolis
tu vas tu vas y aller progressivement
des trucs qui ressemblent à des pâtes en
l'amenant petit à petit d'un truc qui
ressemble de plus en plus à des brocolis
way et au bout du compte un cas d'accord
en short dans l'idéal quand on peut le
but c'est qu'à chaque fois qu'on passe
d'une étape à l'autre on change
seulement écrit terre battue a changé
que la couleur que la forme et c'est en
fonction donc là on a parlé de ce que
toi tu sais avec les enfants ont des
adultes en rééducation mais pour que tu
les entends cabinet faut les amène et
j'imagine que c'est peut-être la partie
la plus la plus difficile c'est pour les
parents de faire le de fer afin de
détecter le trouble est de savoir que ça
existe de là s'il ya des parents qui
nous regardent des ados qui qu'on a des
soucis avec la voiture
toi tu d'accès quoi les signes qui
doivent alerter et le dira peut-être il
ya trouble de l'ordre de l'oralité
alimentaire qu'il faut dans tuellement
réduction en tout cas à prendre en
charge les signes ça serait quoi alors
lucile numéro un c est ce qu il ya
souffrance c'est à dire est ce que
l'enfant le parent ou les deux ans
souffre certes que typiquement un ado
qui demain va venir et me dire bah moi
je mange des pâtes des arrivées et des
gnocchis et ça me va très bien et j'ai
aucun problème socialement ça sert à
rien comment c'est de toute façon parce
que c'est des prises en charge tellement
fastidieuse que ça vaut pas le coup par
contre un enfant qui pourrait avoir un
panel d'animaux plus élargie mais qui en
souffrent qui est pas bien qui dit tous
les jours j'aimerais bien manger comme
les autres et avec des parents qui sont
en pleurs à la fin de chaque repas etc
en fait pour moi c'est le critère numéro
au c'est là dessus que je vais décider
si je prends en charge
un patient et sa famille ou pas et donc
je dirais que le signe c'est faites vous
confiance c'est à dire que on est
entouré de malheureusement pro de santé
qui sont pas encore toujours très au
courant et on va encore avoir des
professionnels de santé parfois des
pédiatres en qui on a beaucoup confiance
qu'ils vont dire vous inquiétez pas
alors les deux phrases cetc du caprice
il faut forcer et l'autre phrase c'est
un enfant se laisse pas mourir de faim
le caprice ça n'existe pas et les
parents il y en a qui ont essayé de
forcer bas quand l'enfant à tournon ni
sur aucun ces équipes c'est ce qui se
passe voilà s'en sont rendus compte
direct et le un enfant se laisse pas
mourir de faim il ya aussi des parents
faut essayer parce qu'on leur a dit si
si si vous ne lâchez pas et en fait ils
ont vu leurs enfants ne rien manger
pendant 24 48 heures enfin ils ont fini
par dire là c'est pas possible ridicule
donc pour les parents ils peuvent se
faire confiance et s'il ya souffrance ça
vaut le coup de consulter et ce que
j'aime bien leur dire aussi c'est que si
jamais on se sent pas tout à fait
écouter par un pro que ces improbables
qui est pas hyper sensibilisés à ça on
consent pas très à l'aise on a le droit
d'aller demander un second thème c'est
même plutôt penser c'est plutôt
conseillé alors les gens ont parfois
peur mais c'est ni du manque de respect
ni un manque de confiance qu'il n'a pas
de problème donc je sais que
malheureusement les parents encore jeudi
doivent se battre pas mal pour dire s'il
ya un problème et qu'il finisse enfin
par trouver après parfois on fait plus
et du coup parce que là en vrai
de ce que tu racontes là
j'ai l'impression que ça peut
potentiellement concerner beaucoup
d'enfants parce que
j'ai vu plein d'amis avec leur gamin qui
voulaient rien manger où ça finissait
toujours en crise de larmes et c'était
systématique et c'est là on est a priori
très typiquement dans des enfants qui
mériterait une prise en charge
mais comme tu dis les pros de santé
qu'on va voir dans ce moment-là
peut-être un médecin de famille un peu à
l'ancienne reine du coup qu'est ce que
tu peux conseiller aux parents dans ces
cas-là d'heure qui peuvent se tourner
pour pas qu'on a juste qu'on leur dise
on va oublier est ce qu'il ya des
décembre de référence est ce qu'il ya
des spécialistes à voir en particulier à
ce que parce qu'ils peuvent se tourner
mouais ça c'est pas évident je connais
pas de centre de référence on a quelques
hôpitaux et à necker qui a un service
dédié mais en fait c'est vraiment des
cas très graves et s'il perd difficile
de passer toutes les étapes pour arriver
à necker et je connais aussi un centre à
lyon après je connais moins les autres
villes je dirais que heureusement
maintenant avec internet on peut se
former s'informer en tout cas au maximum
il ya aussi pas mal de plaquettes
explicatives et je sais qu'il ya des
parents qui essaye au silva d'amener de
la documentation c'est ça un peu dommage
d'en arriver là mais ses deux parents
qui amènent de la documentation et qui
tissent basse ici là je suis convaincu
alors faut savoir que de toute façon
pour rencontrer une orthophoniste il
faudra une ordonnance ont donc bah
faudra trouver d'avoir un médecin qui
accepte de faire cette ordonnance est
ensuite est bas les orthophonistes c'est
un peu le même problème on n'a pas le
droit d'afficher nos spécialités sur une
liste ou quoi que ce soit donc en fait
les on n'a pas de liste officielle vient
pas de répertoire les orthophonistes
spécialistes non parce que dans notre
convention en fait on n'a pas le droit
de se faire de pub donc en fait ce
serait estimée par ce serait considéré
comme aller récupérer toutes ces
pathologies là
tu sais chez les collègues donc ça il y
en a pas donc c'est super on se fait pas
de pub comme si on manquait de patients
mais en fait en pratique balayant
vachement embêté et donc pour trouver un
marteau et balle aille seule solution
fait d'appeler toutes les orthodoxes et
leur demander est ce que vous faites y'a
pas pascal inverse il n'y a pas des
associations de parents qui eux or elle
devra dire bah nous on va voir tel ou
tel talent orthophoniste parce qu'elle
est spécialisée là dedans alors je sais
qu'il ya quand même des listes qui
circule sur internet il ya des blogs il
ya des trucs donc en traînant un peu sur
les réseaux par mois du coup je suis
beaucoup sur instagram la prévention ont
donné des infos et où je sais que sur un
style pas mal de gens il y en a qui qui
discutent entre eux il ya des groupes de
parents sur facebook donc je sais que
les infos arrivent à passer quand même
c'est vrai que ça reste prestigieux bon
mais ça finit par passer j'imagine
transmettant à pezens blanc explorer
dans sedan c'est dans cette direction là
tu finis toujours par tomber sur des
gens tout beau me déconseille d'ailleurs
on parle de réseaux sociaux toutes été
assez active sur sur un staff facebook
tik tok est savamment andres a donc déjà
je t'imagine que l'on mettra évidemment
des liens dans la description froide et
puissent y aller voir ses parents équipe
et c'est ça le la lente reprise la
marque ou à dire ses parents équipe et
donc il ya effectivement un site
internet avec un petit livre d'activités
pour aider les gens soient en parallèle
sont en attendant et si non ce
principalement des réseaux sociaux avec
du coup beaucoup de contenu gratuit
au fur et à mesure que je remplis mais
oui c'est ça hein ça part en équipe et
sur un style et sur tille tôt possible
et sur facebook aussi oui au facebook et
un ca sont renvoyés ouais c'est ça c'est
le même contenu mais après selon les
gens c'est important qu'ils aient de
quoi tout le monde et pas sur un stade
ok
on en a déjà un petit peu on a déjà un
petit peu parlé mais du coup le côté
un enfant se laisse pas mourir de faim
ne confirmerait que c'est c'est faux de
dire ça en fait ouais la fameuse ouais
c'est quelque chose que les parents
entendent beaucoup mais c'est
complètement faux et toutes les
hospitalisations pour dénutrition le
prouve en fait ces enfants là c'est
comme ges émis du caprice ni un manque d
envie c'est vraiment une phobie c'est un
blocage en fait si on les aide pas et
que vous les laisse juste à mourir de
faim c'est ce qui va se passer je ne
sais pas parce qu'on le met devant une
assiette de brocolis et qu'on lui dit
tant que tu t'es pas tant que t'as pas
manger ton assiette tu te lèves pas ça
ne fonctionnera pas donc effectivement
un enfant peut se laisser mourir de faim
et ça les parents sont rentrés très vite
quand ils le savent de toute façon est
beaucoup beaucoup actuellement se bat
pour que cette info passe et c'est
compliqué mais ça commence petit à petit
à faire son bout de chemin mais oui un
enfant peut malheureusement se laisser
là on a beaucoup parlé d'eux
ton domaine là la rééducation par une
orthophoniste mais est ce que c'est une
prise en charge qui peut être
pluridisciplinaire à ce qu il yad autres
professionnels de santé lors desquelles
on puisse tourner aussi la danse et dans
ces cas là ouais c'est ça fait partie
des recommandations du coût de la chasse
à ce niveau là
la haute autorité de santé
incroyable ces professionnels de santé
avec leur jargon insupportable donc oui
la haute autorité de santé conseille
effectivement
saadi raynaud ms aussi ça je pense que
les gens que commencer l'organisation
voilà on est dans une période où tout le
monde connaît donc effectivement c'est
recommandé mais c'est d'avoir une prise
en charge pluridisciplinaire
alors outre atlantique ça se fait
beaucoup ils ont pour le coup des
centres comme tu me demandais tout à
l'heure avec tous les pros qui sont
réunis qui connaissent les enfants qui
les prennent tous en charge chez nous ça
n'existe pas a priori je crois pas
qu'ils aient projet pour l'instant mais
c'est l'idéal donc on peut avoir
effectivement une heure tôt les argots
thérapeute propose des choses est assez
proche de ce que les autos peuvent faire
on est assez proches les unes des autres
c'est pas et certaines psychopathes sont
formés comme autriche votre seul oui
c'est comme au temps des siens savent
pas son fort mais on peut avoir des
psychologues dans la boucle dans
certains cas c'est très recommandé
notamment chez les ados et adultes
désormais dans le dsm 5 il ya un nouveau
diagnostic donc un diagnostic d'art fidh
et ce diagnostic là en fait entre donc
puisqu'il aimait le dsm 5 dans les
pathologies psychiatriques et donc mars
id c'est un trouble de l'oralité
alimentaire qui s'est aggravée chez
l'ado ou l'adulte d'accord et donc là la
composante psychologique on ne peut plus
les cartes et et on doit à tout prix la
prendre en charge donc non pas que ce
que c'est j'ai déjà entendu ça avec l'un
de mes passions ça veut pas dire que
c'est dans leur tête et ça veut dire que
toutes ces mauvaises expériences
accumulées ont fini par avoir un impact
énorme et que là par contre on a besoin
d'être à ce niveau là aussi et puis
ensuite évidemment on a besoin de
médecins dans la boucle parfois on peut
avoir des gastros pédiatre etc je sais
qu'il ya d'autres professions qui
peuvent s'ajouter il ya parfois la kiné
évidemment les conseillères en lactation
pour les plus petits et puis certaines
personnes ont tenté par exemple des
choses comme l'hypnose alors c'est pas
encore prouvé ni validé pour le coup
mais
il ya plusieurs adultes et adolescents
notamment qui ont vu les bénéfices ok si
tu devais
si tu devais donner un ou deux conseils
comme ça où soit des parents qui savent
plus quoi faire avec leurs enfants
soient à quelqu'un de plus plus âgés qui
prend en charge tout seul et qui sait
plus quoi faire avec avec lui-même
qu'est ce que tu pourrais donner comme
comme conseil les deux équipes viennent
se serait pas de seins comme je répète
tout en faites vous confiance vraiment
si vous sentez que quelque chose ne va
pas quelque chose
et deuxièmement de paris c'était tout ça
c'est à dire que effectivement c'est
très dur pour l'instant encore d'être
diagnostiquée ça prend du temps mais les
listes d'attentes très longue mais
heureusement on a quand même quelque
chose de génial avec internet et les
réseaux sociaux et donc il ya beaucoup
de groupes de paroles de page instagram
de tik tok maintenant de chaîne youtube
pas encore mais il ya des endroits où on
peut tous se retrouver ou les patients
et parents de patients peuvent échanger
entre eux et où il ya quand même de plus
en plus de professionnels de santé comme
moi qui sont là pour partager du contenu
d'une part mais aussi répondre aux
questions soutenir et échangé parce que
ça ta ta ta ta ces deux étapes de
découvrir que ce dont tu souffres c'est
quelque chose qui existe comme ça non et
du coup que ça peut se prendre en charge
donc ça c'est c'est j'imagine que déjà
quand a mis le pied dans ce dans ce
cette dynamique là ça doit déjà est un
premier grand soulagement pour les
familles pour les enfants oui j'ai
beaucoup de parents qui me disent en
fait bah le jour où on a vu le nom sur
la page internet on a fondu en larmes et
il ya comme un poids qui ce qui
s'évaporait parce que c'est quand même
des parents qui sont très très
culpabiliser montrait préjugés il ya
toujours quand même ce truc qu'on
retrouve un petit peu en autisme et dans
le handicap à 1,2 à ces du comportement
il est élevé
faut le forcer un petit peu donc cédé
par an non seulement ils ont cette
difficulté de voir leurs enfants manger
très mal alors que c'est important pour
des parents et en plus ils ont la double
peine de l'entourage que ce soit perso
ou pro qui va venir en rajouter les
casser les juges aient toujours dire
qu'en fait il aurait fait autrement donc
c'est des parents qui se retrouvent
souvent très seule et dans une très très
grande souffrance et donc en général
quand il découvre que ça a un nom que
ils ont bien fait de se faire confiance
et que on ne s'ajuste pas écouté en
général il ya ce creux sous la joue là
on a beaucoup parlé d'enfants mais les
trucs de l'oralité alimentaire ça
concerne aussi les adultes ça donne quoi
quand on grandit on fait pas des
caprices mais quand on commence à ce
comment ça se manifeste pas exactement
on parle quasiment que des enfants mais
en fait ces enfants là deviennent des
adultes alors comme je le disais dans le
pire des cas ça peut devenir un art fidh
donc avec cette difficulté psychologique
de phobie très grave qui s'est installée
alors après ce qu'il faut voir aussi
c'est que à l'âge adulte on n'attend pas
les mêmes choses d'un enfant que d'un
adulte un enfant on va vous demander de
manger en collectivité mans jusqu'en du
prêt par s'adapter et c'est en fait il
ya beaucoup d'adultes qui garde un truc
de wright et alimentaires et ça passe
complètement inaperçue parce que en fait
ils s'adaptent
mois pour le coup j'ai un truc de
variété alimentaire on s'en est jamais
rendu compte quand j'étais plus jeune
parce que je m'adapte et il y avait des
petits indices quand même parce que ma
mère médecin me faisais de la pizza au
petit déjeuner à ce que je mange
donc je décongeler de la pizza ou je
mangeais 10 soit 600 y avait des indices
mais en fait mon entourage s'est adapté
en disant c'est comme ça pour l'instant
et ça passera et aujourd'hui en fait que
je mange pas de bananes par exemple ça
ne se voit pas pendant quelque chose
parce que un adulte n'ai jamais forcé de
manger un aliment rigeur serreau pas lui
même appris à priori j'en veux pas
personne ici tu manges exactement ça
veut dire qu'en gros même un adulte qui
mangerait aucun légume aucune créditer
sa peu passé relativement inaperçu et
la personne ça donne par contre il ya
aussi toute une partie des ados et des
adultes qui ont des troubles plus
importants ou qui en souffre beaucoup
plus et là bas qui vont avoir notamment
une problématique d'isolement social qui
vont refuser leur part refusé les
invitations alors avec plein d'excusés
j'ai déjà mangé un ballon j'ai pas très
fin où j'ai pas le temps et la sa valise
iso donc là encore j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup d'ados et d'adultes qui pensent
que c'est foutu pour eux c'est trop tard
rires en fait d'une ressorte tu peux
faire quelque chose aussi pour pour les
way we are c'est pareil on n'entend pas
encore beaucoup parler aux états unis
sont beaucoup plus prises en charge et
moi tout mon travail est basé sur des
recherches un peu perso que j'ai fait
sur des ressources anglo saxonne mais ça
vient tranquillement et on peut les
aider est là aussi s'il ya souffrance
faut vraiment pas rester tout seul c'est
ça la chine c'est le même que pour les
enfants c'est mme arthur moment où il ya
souffrance ça mérite qu'on se penche
même problème est ce que tu voudrais je
sais pas peut-être conclure avec un mot
de la fin on a déjà dit pas mal de pas
mal de choses lors les enfants
difficiles et d'enfant capricieux cc
c'est plus compliqué que ça mais est-ce
que globalement tu vois à conclure sur
quelque chose de particulier je pense
qu'on a tout dit mais si de dire qu' il
ya des solutions il ya des solutions et
on est beaucoup de professionnels de
santé à pouvoir aider les gens à avoir
fait des études pour ça et du coup il ya
des solutions ça à le faire et voilà sur
les réseaux pas hésité à nous rejoindre
pour pour en discuter et pour réparer
tout ça et bien c'est dit voilà bêtise
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]